brian liam is the founder executive
chairman and former chief executive
office of c-span born and raised in
Lafayette Indiana he earned a degree
from Purdue University before joining
the United States Navy after various
jobs in the communication field
including a stint in the Pentagon public
affairs office during the Vietnam War he
founded the nonprofit channel in 1979
lamb has conducted over 1,000 interviews
in his lifetime starting in high school
and continuing on c-span programs
including book notes and Q&A he has
compiled multiple books from his work on
book notes including book notes on
American character
I don't trust David for choosing this
student to introduce me because she has
the same name as my wife Victoria so
making me feel at home right away thank
you very much I have to tell you as
Victoria said I'm a graduate of Purdue
University and I have been involved in
the last couple years and setting up
washington-based program and I'd never
thought that I would use the word ND but
seeing this place makes me very envious
because we bring 20 students in May and
we house them in one room over c-span
where we do our interaction with people
and this place is just magnificent I am
sure you students know that I want to
make sure that we get a microphone over
here we do have it now because one of
the things I like to do best is ask
people questions instead of talking
don't mind answering questions and I'll
be glad to the hillsdale college and she
spent have one very important thing in
common we take no government money under
any circumstances anytime anywhere
anyplace and I've supposedly founded the
network but really if you I was
completely accurate there were about
twenty two people that founded c-span
they were all business people they own
cable television companies they offered
the money up in the very beginning in
1977 originally for the sole purpose of
creating a public service there is no
government money involved in it
whatsoever and that's kind of one of the
themes that I like to talk about with
folks and that is the whole experience
of money what impact it has on you where
it comes from and one thing I like to
say is that whatever you see on
television the first thing you ought to
ask is where do they get their money
that will tell you everything about why
they're doing what they're doing doesn't
mean that they're bad or good depending
on where their money comes from it just
means that it will tell you that if it's
a commercial driven network they need
eyeballs to sell the commercial
advertisers and if they don't get them
they're out of business and that's one
of the things that happened to Al Gore's
network current he could not get the
eyeballs although
he found in a country that would spend
500 million dollars on buying it back so
he was able to get a tremendous return
on his money which is unusual because
people want access more than anything
else but that's been our secret
everything we do is based on where money
comes from it comes from all these
different companies no one company has
control we have a board of directors of
21 and we have a very important by law
that says no board member can have
anything to say about programming and
that was a creation of one of our board
members because I remember saying to him
one day you know I haven't gotten much
negative feedback from our industry
about what we've covered but it always
makes me nervous that somebody's going
to call me one day and say if you don't
cover this or if you do cover this we're
going to cut off your money and he said
well I think the best thing you do is
just put a new bylaw and that suggests
that they can't have any statement so he
did and it's been a great streets I've
always thought it was a similar story to
the founding of the country it's not
that big a deal but it was created by a
group of people who had no real
experience in news and information but
agreed to the concept and the mission
and we're here to 12 34 years later
actually basically 36 years if you count
the creation time and all that so that's
the background more than anything else
that I wanted you to know is where the
money comes from now students who's got
the microphone I want to ask you all why
you're here just that simple question
why are you here why do you go to
Hillsdale and why are you here in
Washington and anybody take me up on
that offer and tell us who you are my
name is Malika willoughby and I'm
actually one of only two Hillsdale
students on this row of here the rest
are bus are interning but I chose
Hillsdale because of the respect that I
saw between the professors and the
students and they wanted to be where
they were and they could all answer the
question what is a liberal arts
education and they knew what the mission
of the school was what is a liberal
education oh well from what I've come to
know at school it's studying the Great's
of who have gone before us so that we
can stand on their shoulders so studying
the best minds that have applied
themselves to philosophy art music so
that we can gain from them and continue
learning in those capacities good job I
like to ask somebody who's not going to
hillsdale but who is here to tell me why
you're here don't be timid got to keep
this moving somebody put your hand up
thank you my name is Jessica cruzan I go
to school in danville kentucky and its
centre college it is a small liberal
arts school as well and i'm interning
across the street at the Heritage
Foundation and do you want me to answer
why I'm here sure but Center you go to
center Center College where the vice
presidential debate was this past
election and the election before was it
but they were there yeah there have been
two there I want to ask I've never asked
anybody from senators what is it in the
water there that allows you to have two
major debates on your campus we have a
very resourceful and fantastic president
that everybody really respects there so
your president knows how to raise money
yeah
money story number one so why are you
here I'm here because being in DC I
think is a fantastic opportunity for me
to just gain a lot of null as much
knowledge I can from a lot of great
minds that hang out here so what is the
number one thing you would tell your
parents or your closest friend back home
about Washington DC not about this
program but about what you learned about
Washington you can't trust anyone but
but you can learn from everyone and also
you have to always be dressed to impress
because you never know who you're going
to meet on these streets that's pretty
darn good I'm so sorry to hear you can't
trust anyone ah I've been in this town
for 47 years and I guess I'm naive I
still trust everyone in Washington who
else has something you want to tell us
come on you folks look like he knows
them pass it right to your next door
neighbor there you didn't know you're
gonna have to work when you came here
today tell it tell us who you are um my
name is Courtney Murphy and I go to
baylor university down in texas and i'm
also in turning across the street at the
Heritage Foundation you know ken starr i
dunno kenstar I've met him once what
would you say about him he also knows
how to get the money in um he also knows
know how to get basketball baseball hey
I get sports programs going to I guess
mm-hmm do you play sports I don't
intramurals but that's about it so what
about Washington what have you learned
about Washington may be surprised you um
pick anything I mean I've learned a lot
um I was here last summer as well and I
think just learning the whole how how
the government works and how one thing
that surprised me the most was how
there's a bunch of 25 year olds up here
running the government
I that was probably the most interesting
thing that I learned when I first came
here I was in the Navy but I at 20 h 26
I was the press secretary for a senator
and I wouldn't say that we ran the
office I say a lot of 26 year old tried
to run the other he would remind us from
time to time that he was the senator and
he was elected which a lot of them ought
to do more often than they do how about
over thank you how about over here is
there a microphone on this side pass it
to Victoria there I want to know a
little bit more about her Victoria why
did you come to Washington and what have
you found since you've been here um I
found well I came to Washington because
I was very inspired by the grassroots
movement and all the work they've been
doing and I kind of wanted to see if
there was a part that I could play and
since I've been here I would agree i was
very surprised the average age of the
staffers i kind of thought they were all
interns and i learned they weren't um
and I've also just kind of been
surprised at how small this town is and
how interconnected everything is as well
that was definitely something I've
learned if one of your good friends it's
where you go school I go to hillsdale
college and if one of your good friends
had was preparing to choose where she or
he would go next what would you tell him
about Washington would you would you
give him some advice that not expect to
give him a couple years ago well if it's
a girl I would say bring Flatts not
heels and but on a serious note I would
say just to be prepared to be kind of to
be prepared to take in all the
information that's going to be coming at
you this there's just so much going on
in this town it's very hard to kind of
look at the big picture and not get
caught up in the small detail so i would
just say bring a notebook and just open
your ears and open your eyes to
everything did I get there I isn't
Mikayla said to her yeah Victoria pass
the microphone to her I'll ask her a
couple questions because she's been very
quiet over there
if you want to get the news and you do
some writing as it is now tell us where
you're interning I work at the oh I'm an
intern at the Leadership Institute and I
write for their campus newspaper called
campus or form online so if you were
telling somebody or go first tell us
where you get most of your information a
lot of our information comes from tips
from students that we have gained
connections with and the rest of it is
just personal research and learning
where to look for news and so a lot of
what we try to do is to break news and
not just to try and recycled things and
repackage it in a different manner
what's your number one personal news
source for national current events that
i personally where do you go in the
morning to learn what's going on in the
world I can't say that there's one um I
I obviously like I look at Fox I look at
the wall street journal I look at the
spectator there's a lot of different
things that depends on the day well just
reflect thank you I was reflecting on my
own situation when i came here in 1966
there are people in this audience i can
tell i wouldn't dare point you out that
probably are around my age and in 1966
for instance this wasn't here the
heritage foundation wasn't there fox
news didn't exist and we didn't exist
and i think one of the things i learned
about myself was that I wasn't really
ready to learn when I went to college I
think in some ways I should have taken a
couple years and gone somewhere and done
something else I actually spent four
years in the Navy and if I'd had done
that first I might have been more
serious about learning David mentioned
when the first was up here about
Tocqueville the interesting thing for me
was I didn't have any idea who
Tocqueville was and I started
interviewing people I did a book show
for 16 years called book notes and I
would sit down every week with an author
hardback nonfiction and I would only I
set it up so I would only interview them
once I would not go back to the same
well all the time so over a period of
the
16 years I did 801 separate interviews
with 801 different authors and along the
way I discovered this guy Tocqueville or
as some people call him believe it or
not Tocqueville tuck ville de
Tocqueville de Tocqueville de
Tocqueville it seems that everybody has
a different way to pronounce his name
and I got so interested in it that I
working with our own group over there I
suggested we go find out who he was and
so back in nineteen ninety seven or
eight I can't remember the exact date we
decided to do a 55 city tour going from
Washington DC and Rhode Island where he
first went to all through 11 think it
was eleven nine or eleven states and he
in 55 communities we took our big bus
there and we did a program highlighting
what happened there and the reason I
mentioned that is in in the course of
this we found I found out one night when
I was speaking in Springfield Illinois
to the Abraham Lincoln Association the
guy comes up to me I said we're going to
go follow Tocqueville around this guy
comes up after the dinners over when he
said you know there's a chateau we're at
Oakville used to live and that at that
moment it was the first time I'd ever
heard that and he said it's over in
France it's actually in a small
community called Tocqueville and I got
very excited I mean one of the great
things about not doing what I should
have done in college is that I had this
incredible appetite to learn once I got
beyond that got into this town and
started seeing experiencing history so I
said our group we're going to we're
going to Tokyo we're going to see if we
can do a program over there and we ended
up doing a live show on a saturday
morning in the middle of the rain from
Tocqueville France with the descendents
it's really kind of a stretch but with
great great grand nieces
and was our he owned the own the chateau
you know that's it and he also had a son
named Alexei which helped us and he had
a dog named gota actually I tell you a
story about gota which has nothing to do
with anything but we went and because
it's one of the more embarrassing things
that's ever happened to me we all went
out to lunch as we were surveying the
place and when right after landing the
old the de French love garlic and most
of us love garlic so I had had something
that had lots of garlic in it and I
decided to pop something that I
shouldn't have talked to peace ago in my
mouth and I was quietly chewing as we
came back to the Chateau and we had to
count with us count durable was his name
and the son Alexei and it was very
exciting and some bunch of c-span people
and we're looking at a way to have a
show over there so I realized that
chewing gum wasn't the most
sophisticated thing to do so I took a
piece of gum out and just tossed it the
unfortunate thing was that the gum
landed on the side of go to the dog it
was a black dog and it was a white piece
of gum and I looked over and saw that
and said you know if the if the count
sees is I'm toast I mean that you know
talk about unsophisticated so I decided
as he's talking to people to go over to
try to get the gum off the side of the
dog so I reached down and pulled I mean
first of all it was a big dog big black
dog I reached down kind of this way to
pull it off and what I realized was I
pulled the gum up but there was a long
string of gum and I'm thinking and this
is a silly story but I'm thinking if I
get caught this is going to really be
stupid I did get away with getting the
gum off but it was one of those things
where you know I couldn't quite get it
off my hands the good news was the count
didn't want to shake hands with me at
any time
so I was pretty much home free but the
more important story and the thing that
has some tied a c-span and I always have
felt this is a bit of a stretch but the
original c-span was James Madison
because James Madison took all the notes
at the Constitutional Convention and I
don't know that he got every word down
he certainly did but he that was the you
know they the difference was in those
days they hammered the window shut in
Philadelphia so in a hot made of
September it must have been very painful
in there to have to sit in there but he
didn't know until a long time after that
exactly what was said but James Madison
at I think he was I like to say he was
only five foot two and 100 pounds was
the guy that recorded all this then when
I got more involved in the Tocqueville
story and those of you who have never
thought about Tocqueville I suspect all
hillsdale students have and been taught
about Tocqueville might remember that he
came to this country in 1831 he was 25
years old and he came with a buddy of
his named gustav beaumont de Beaumont if
you're French bigger in our vernacular
be Gus Beaumont is who it would be in Al
Tocqueville but the one thing that he
did and we had these made up when we did
this series on Tocqueville were these
little booklets and he had he there are
only 14 pages I had these made up just
to show off and he would he had 14 of
them that he filled with his chicken
scratches about what he learned when he
went around the United States and so
that's how he recorded the basics of
what he ended up writing in democracy in
america and when we got there only thing
i wanted i learned that in the garret of
the Chateau were all of these mccallum
Calle Calle 'he's and
little notebooks and I just wanted to
see one of them and we got the count to
agree to take us up into the garret but
when we got up there we learned that the
count was and it was beautiful in this
round room and all these boxes full of
Tocqueville letters and everything the
count was only willing to show us one
document and that was the first letter
that Tocqueville wrote when he was five
years old and I had asked our producer
who was French please ask I want us I
just want to see one ka that's all I
want to see I want to see what it looks
like i won't hurt it he can hold it I
don't need to hold it although i would
like to and the count refuse and she
refused to ask him and it was really
kind of a French standoff between the
French and the Americans over this one
small little issue so when we did our
live program we had a guest on who was
the foremost expert on Tocqueville her
name was France woz Maloney oh and she
was a member of the insider group and
was a friend of the families and all
that and she sat on the set with us and
she had a Caillou so I figured I was
going to get around it somehow or
another and so in the middle of the
program I said to France woz would you
mind if I looked at that up close and
she handed it to me and that's how I got
my hands on one cai it means nothing to
anybody but me and but the reason I
mention it again was the old-fashioned
way of documenting what went on and
compare that to what we're doing today
and I want to go back to the students
because i want to ask them about today's
way of categorizing a nut category
cataloging all this information how do
you keep track of what's going on and do
you use twitter facebook instant
messaging email all that stuff when we
the answer yeah ok
I actually last night just wrote down
that Twitter is a tool as his facebook
and so yes I do use them but i try to be
purposeful in the way that i use them i
use i obviously use email i eat a lot of
blogs that's how I keep up with my news
and then there are certain websites that
I'll go to as well do you doubt do I
count tout tout does anybody know what
touting is is it like clouding know any
of your students know what touting if
you tapped it's a similar thing to
Twitter but it's a 15 second video that
people often send out and they have to
keep it to 15 seconds how about somebody
else telling us how you use all this new
fandangled stuff and whether it's good
or bad for us who has an opinion that
hasn't spoken bring that mic down here
they're not unless I point to them
they're distant there we go tell us who
you are I'm Meg Goodman I'm from
southwest baptist university in missouri
and i'm interning at the Heritage
Foundation and I'm kind of like Malika i
use facebook and twitter just to kind of
keep up with what's going on i read some
blogs as well some new sites and i think
a lot of it is just really condensed
like you get the surface level of all
these things that are going on but you
really have to do the research on your
own if you want to get anything that's
substantive so I don't know it's a good
way to have like a general idea of
what's going on but you have to do the
work on your own if you really want to
know about a specific issue I think
what's your reaction to what's going on
right now with the Snowden release of
all the documents um it's kind of scary
um there's I mean there's a lot in the
news about it right now so I kind of
feel like it's all over the place but I
need to do some more research on it are
you how do you feel about this whole
idea that we can capture all this stuff
put it on servers keep it forever and I
mean I think it's kind of terrifying I'm
an accounting major so you want to keep
track of things but I don't think those
things need to be kept track of so we
passed that to somebody else that hasn't
talked here but we have just
passed a milestone in c-span we have
200,000 hours of c-span video available
to the public free of charge on our
video library and those of you who have
never been there he'd be bowled over by
what is there and you can get on by just
going to see day span org and especially
if you're a student you can have a ball
putting together a good presentation for
your class what is your name hi I'm
Danielle debose and I'm from the
University of Alabama what do you yet
you don't have an accent d uh probably
not a big one well what's your reaction
to all this new see for us this is new
for you you've lived with it as you grew
up I mean it's overwhelming for us to
everyone says that the young people love
all the social media but it's a good
thing but it also it seems like too much
information at time so I think it'd be
helpful too I think it's helpful to find
what you believe is reliable new sources
and turn to that and not have a million
followers on Twitter do you tweet I'm
not a big tweeter of my own thoughts I
don't know how I retreat a lot of things
but it's kind of hard to come up with a
very clever thing to say on Twitter so
thank you just a little background on
c-span if you've never paid any
attention to that all open it up to any
question you might have we have 280
people that work at c-span and we're
located right over on Capitol Hill right
here on Capitol Hill but we're over
there on north capitol street about a
block from the Senate and we have three
networks she spent 12 and three some
parts of the country don't get three you
can get all three on the internet from
at your desk if you want to watch it we
are a public service to the cable
industry as i said earlier and they pay
for it at a rate of about sixty two
three million dollars a year we've been
in business on the air since 1979 an
awful lot of the people that work there
are from this area I'm trying
get as many people from Purdue as I can
in there to straighten out the place but
we only have half dozen most there but
it's it's a lot of folks that went to
University of Maryland University of
Virginia and around the district George
Washington and George Mason and all and
we have an internship for each season
some of you who haven't thought about
your intentions for the future be sure
to keep us in mind because it's an
opportunity for you to get inside a
place like ours which is your ticket to
the Future one of the hardest things
about getting a job these days is just
getting in for every job that we have
available we get about 200 applicants
which is most of them aren't qualified
for it but they're reaching out as you
know to whatever source they can our
mission is very simple and that is to
put our cameras in front of as many
different political events as we can
including the house and the Senate and
the hearings we do about 2,000 hours of
hearings every year and to do it every
day all the time so that when I as I
grew up if it networks were motivated
they would cover an event if they
weren't motivated they wouldn't cover an
event and that was most of the time even
though the news divisions might want to
cover something the people that collect
the money and paid the bills would say
not on your life and there are a lot of
stories about news people that wanted to
cover hearings and they started out
covering them and then they all of a
sudden said no we can't do this anymore
we're losing money on the deal there's
almost nothing that we do that hasn't
been done before but it's never been
done in a concentrated way which allows
you to be guaranteed that you can see
almost every hearing that goes on from
start to finish I will say this in the
last couple of years very quietly
without anybody really knowing it your
friendly federal government mostly the
Senate in the house has spent a lot of
your money on doing the same thing we're
doing putting cameras in the hearing
rooms streaming it online
the White House has a major website
that's incredibly successful and that
goes back to the old days and we've
heard forever the politicians want to
speak directly to their constituents
they don't want to have to fool with the
middle person and you know in spite of
the fact that I like the idea that they
can have that option that certainly
would be a bad way to run a country you
need people in the middle of all that no
matter what you think of their politics
because as you know when they're
spending our money it might be a good
idea for somebody else other than the
government to look after it we have 74
inspectors general in the government in
this town they matter a lot but even
with that you can't be sure that you're
going to get all the things going on
that we should know about anyway that's
a little bit of a background if anybody
in the room has a question that they'd
like to ask I'll do the best I can to
try to answer it silence yes sir yes sir
I just like to thank you for coming talk
to us and one thing I'd like to ask you
to share with us is how you 800 sounds
like a lot but it's not very many when
he comes around me books are published +
OA done it a small number how do you
decide which ones to do I was recently
watched your interview with Carol
barklow who wrote in the men's house and
was very impressed with the questions
that you asked and I just wondered how
you make a decision to do an interview
with an author on the book well I give
you an example of about today I just
came from doing an interview with a
fellow named George Packer who writes
for The New Yorker and he has a book out
called the unwinding which I found I
looked at it and found it very
interesting but we had not decided for a
lot of different reasons that we were
going to do that interview and we got a
call yesterday saying he was in town and
at the last minute he agreed to come in
at ten fifteen I went home yesterday
afternoon early and dived into this book
which I found very interesting and he
has done a number of things in the book
that you might find interesting
he comes from The New Yorker and
immediately I'm sure you would think
that is a particular political
persuasion but I found it difficult in
this book to see any real strong bias
about what who is reporting on and he
does vignettes on 10 different Americans
that he wrote off of the books that they
had written and that's from Newt
Gingrich to Oprah Winfrey and he also
highlights some areas of the country
Tampa Silicon Valley and he was born out
there and also the third part of Wall
Street then he found three people that
he followed for months and months a
fellow from North Carolina one from Ohio
near youngstown and the other one was a
former aide to Joe Biden and his premise
is that we started unwinding probably in
Vietnam then in Watergate and then he
takes us from about nineteen seventy
eight which is we started in 1979 up
till now it wasn't a scientific decision
there wasn't an idiotic Ariz enforcer
Packer was an original supporter of the
Iraq war he wrote a book called
assassins gate which was all about Iraq
he spent a lot of time over there and it
was the last minute decision sometimes
however there's a book that I'm reading
that I'll do I think it's next week on
John Hay a brand new book on John a and
John Hay went all the way from being a
secretary to Abraham Lincoln been
Secretary of State he was secretary to
Abraham Lincoln least in his early 20s
he might even have been as young as 19 I
can't remember for sure I haven't really
gotten into the book yet but that's a
historical figure so there's no rhyme or
reason to this except we always have our
eye on the politics if we get somebody
from the left we want to get somebody
from the right and it's it's not
politically correct as a show but I
don't want people sitting out in the
audience missing the point that it's
worth listening to all different sides
before you make up your mind so there is
no rhyme nor reason to it now I will go
back to somebody that we've done
for if they were a particularly
interesting person I just like to learn
it's that simple and I've learned a lot
from those books thanks for the question
anybody over here yeah yes sir to the
very quiet respect respectful group I
sort of wanted to ask you the question
that you were asking a lot of my fellow
interns as someone who's arguably
watched Washington and Congress more
closely than anybody else in this city
what would you tell someone not from
here that you know that they wouldn't
really know from you know normal news
media something that would surprise them
about Congress's actions I don't know I
think one of the reasons that I got
involved in the c-span thing in the
beginning was I came from a small town
in Indiana Lafayette and by the way
you'll find out how strange I am I just
got back from a week in Paris and we
went to Lafayette grave looked all over
the the one thing about it this is a
side story is that when we got to like
its grave you had to really go out of
your way to find it it was behind a
church and you had to wait until three
o'clock in the afternoon and all that
stuff and we found one other human being
in the graveyard when we went to the jim
morrison grave and père Lachaise as I
had done years earlier went to parallel
Shady's not just a Jim Morrison grave
it's just befuddle me why 50 Americans
are standing around there looking at his
gravesite because I never liked him
anyway and I never liked the doors and I
never like I didn't know him but I find
it fascinating that people were falling
over themselves and it's the only grave
site in the entire pere lachaise
cemetery that has oscar wilde and Marcel
Proust and lots of other people in it
that anybody stands around looking at
the grave sites it's a bizarre choice I
would say that you can kind of know now
no matter where you live in the United
States if you've paid attention what
this place is like and that was one of
the reasons that I got involved in this
because when I got here and I looked
around I said you know
my close friends and they're in
Indianapolis and I said they they they
don't know i mean the behind the same
stuff and so one of the things that we
do that you may narrow noticed is that
and this doesn't always happen but
should at the end of every hearing that
we cover every event we stay two minutes
beyond the end of the event and watch
people react to the Chairman and the
members of the committee and the routine
because it's amazing what goes on and if
you're sitting in the room you can see
that and that was one of the things we
started years ago so that people back
there outside of this area could see
that small dynamic we're also the ones
that started covering the dinners I was
befuddled when I got here about these
dinners the White House Correspondents
Dinner the radio and television
Correspondents Dinner I thought it was a
very odd thing that happened you would
go into this ballroom at the Washington
Hilton there'd be 3,000 seats there you
had a table and somebody from a news
organization was inviting a source to
sit there with you and you'd yuk it up
during the night and drink wine and and
hope that the your source got drunken
with day of things that you shouldn't
know and it it was bizarre that that
there was this friendship thing that
everybody tried to develop because I
guarantee you that the farther you get
away from this place the more accurate
you can be on criticism and you know
looking at what goes on here without
having a personal relationship and
knowing people here are nice unless they
are arrogant and they're arrogant when
they begin to get power and they
surround themselves with security that's
the thing that I find absolutely
astounding is how many people in this
town now have security it becomes a
badge of honor I realize that this is an
unsafe world we live in but if you're an
assistant secretary for an oomph and
you've got a security person it's a bit
of a stretch and there's an awful lot of
that going on it makes you feel
important you're always in a hurry
you're always protected at that point
you have really no idea what the real
life is like
and that's one of the first things you
notice when you get up close and
personal I you know I spent two years in
the Senate over there I would never go
back the the reverence for a member of
the Senate that back in those days was
extraordinary and in far as I was
concerned outsized these are just human
beings that went around collecting your
money so they could run have job and we
have overdone it up close and personal
in this town and as far as I'm concerned
I think that's the first thing i noticed
and that people would the reverence the
senator this senator that the senator
wants this is Senator one I was 26 years
old I say when I was a press secretary
and I was appalled by it I just said
this is nuts you know and I said I got
to get out of here I don't want that I
don't want to I don't want to do it any
longer and the White House of course is
far worse than any place in the town the
kool-aid you drink at the beginning
ensures that you will have a very very
prejudiced view of everything that goes
on inside the White House but there are
lots of other things I won't bore you
with it this gentleman here had a
question yes sir you look very familiar
Ken he was one of our scholars in our
Tocqueville series good to see you guys
he's an extraordinary privilege to be
invited with greats like Harvey
Mansfield others on that first
Tocqueville a program from Newport and I
didn't own a television then so I didn't
know much about c-span and so I would i
I've evolved since then and become a
facebook addict and so on but I wanted
to ask you what given that this was your
introduction to Tocqueville what lesson
from Tocqueville or lessons would you
think would be most relevant for people
serving in the government here well you
know what one of the big moments in the
Tocqueville democracy in america is the
quality of the membership in the
Congress that he found when he was here
I won't go into that I don't necessarily
agree with all that but I do agree with
some of that
I took away from Tocqueville something
that it's not terribly intellectual and
that is it's amazing to me that a man 25
years old with his friend could come to
this country travel around meet with a
former president you know the John
Quincy Adams email with another's and
and learn so much about us and as you
know he you know more than I do he was
here supposedly studying the prison
system we've been to all those prisons
where he went to Auburn and to ossining
and places like that but it's just an
amazing success story about and you
folks who are in your 20s end up
possibly doing your most important work
when you're 25 years old I mean he was
what 30 31 when he eventually published
democracy in america the first volume I
was just blown away by how much he
observed and there's so much about in
there about community and religion and
and all the different groups in our
society so I'm not a scholar but I've
often heard people say that outside of
the Federalist Papers it democracy in
America is this most second most
important book on politics that were
written in for this country but you're
the expert that's why we asked you to
talk to us yes back in the back I'm a
rising senior at yale and i'm also an
intern at the Heritage Foundation and we
had a speaker recently come visit who
made several conjectures about how
c-span has changed the way the hill
works so I was wondering if you could
speak on your opinion about how c-span
has affected the way senators and
congressmen conduct their business
that's a question that you know since
the beginning people have wanted to know
what I thought and I don't have any deep
thoughts on it I try not to even think
about it because there are a lot of
people to think it was a terribly bad
idea to put television in the house and
in the Senate I will say this the impact
was it's at anecdotal Ronald Reagan
lochte c-span a lot and I always thought
this is interesting you know of your
Prezi nited states and you come into
this town and you
the election and you nominate people to
be Secretary of whatever that's the last
time you see him they come up to the
hill they testify and the old days the
network's would used 30 seconds on the
evening news and you net had no idea
whatsoever what the give-and-take was
now any president united states can
watch all of his or her eventually
cabinet members testify and so that's
small we had an experience back in 1983
i think it was and it was probably the
single most mind-blowing event of my
entire experience at c-span we had a
group of kids ronald reagan always
wanted to do programs with young king
and he had done those when he was in
california he did him on cable systems
out there and he came to town here and
he had a a that work for him that was
not immediately around him by the name
of Joe homes some of you may have known
him Joe was that old California hand and
he'd often go to the ranch with Ronald
Reagan and he said to him one day said
I'd like to do programs with young
people again and so Joe homes somehow or
another got to us and we went down and
said are you he said were you interested
we said absolutely and so we went got
together with a close-up foundation and
the close-up foundation brings high
school kids to town and agreed he agreed
to do it ended up for programs where he
would come into a room like this
actually the in the Eisenhower EOB it's
the room on the fourth floor 450 i think
it was but he would just sit down
immediately and say what are your
questions and for a half an hour young
people even younger than you all in high
school could ask him questions so but we
would we decided to do after the first
one we were pretty excited about this
because presidents didn't do much of
that back in those days we went back to
the studio over here we brought the
students back in the studio and we
opened the phones up and we opened the
cameras that we went live we ran the
video recorded video of the president
then had people call in and talk about
the experience and asked the young folks
what their what it was like
well that well I don't know how many
minutes into the program up on my screen
comes the next calm and we had calls
from all over the United States that
said Washington DC and I because it was
local in those days you paid a lot of
money for long-distance calls I just let
it sit there for a minute because we had
calls coming in from Hawaii in Montana
and New York and all that and finally up
on my screen said very simply take the
call now
and.and I didn't it didn't track for me
and I punched the button up and I've got
the video of this and I hadn't I had no
idea that my face would ever look this
way but this woman came on with a very
stern voice saying mr Lamb and I said
yes one moment for the President and I
had this ridiculous look on my face like
I just swallowed the cat and the bird at
the same time and we had to wait a few
minutes and all of a sudden he comes on
the line and he said I came back to my
private quarters here and I turned you
on and I saw the students talking about
the exclusionary rule and I think they
don't have it quite right and I want to
set him straight well what I found out
later was that because the troika that
was around him and you know some of the
people there I think in every case is
gotta know in two cases there there was
alive jim baker and ed mason and then
the third one is Dinah my mind's blank
David might be and it turned out that
they did not want him to do the show and
they didn't want him to certainly call a
call-in show and he had gone back to the
private quarters and had this access
open access and he calls the operator
and says get me on that show
well our current chief executive officer
Susan Swain who was at that time about
27 years old and she had just come to
work for us a year earlier she's the one
that is in the back saying take the call
now I can't tell you about the rest of
the stuff there are people who are still
very strongly opposed to television the
former parliamentarian of the house
thinks we've done damage that it's not
the house that used to be Bob Byrd was
the one that originally opposed
television in the Senate and believe it
or not I just found out in an interview
that I did a couple of days ago that
will be on QA on Sunday night's eight
o'clock something that I never put
together Bob Byrd was opposed to it
because of all the things you know about
Bob Byrd in the way he revered the
United States Senate the other one in
the Senate that was absolutely
diametrically opposed to it in a very
strong order was Russell long and
Russell I did not know this in paying
attention to it I should have because
it's one of the things that's changed in
the House and Senate is you have less
drinking after hours there used to be a
lot of that going on and now because
when they step up to the microphone you
can tell and in the early days of c-span
you could tell but Russell long had a
terrible time with alcohol he got
married and his wife is the one that got
him out of it the last ten years of his
life but now it looks in retrospect one
of the things he was worried about was
if he were a little tipsy on the floor
of the Senate it would could be picked
up on television but Bob Byrd went to
Russell long and said Russell it's time
you got to get out of the way it's a new
generation we got to go on television it
took them seven years from when we first
went on in 1979 with the house to 1986
jun 2nd and the way this happens is
always to me very strange boy had
happened in the house why it happened in
the Senate and why it's not happening
yet in the Supreme Court but the Supreme
Court has the least to lose personally
in the sense
they are not up for re-election but
because they have the least to lose
personally and they think the most to
lose professionally they don't let
cameras in the Supreme Court at this
point but it's a very human thing and if
we ever get in the Supreme Court the
reason will be because a couple of
members say our country doesn't know
what we do and how we do it and it's
time that they see what is a fabulous
institution how this thing works but I
didn't really answer your question
because I don't like I don't like to
suggest that we made that big a
difference it's in the eye of the
beholder next question yes sir all eyes
are on him as he gets there can I ask
you to answer the same question you
started with follow the money why does
what causes 22 cable executives to pony
up 60 million dollars a year for c-span
well the way it started was I was
working for trade publications in this
town called cable news magazine and I
wanted to do I thought I always thought
that that we had this juggernaut ABC NBC
and CBS and as good at people as they
are let's not be disparaging you may not
have liked their politics but they
weren't bad people they were trying to
do what they thought was the right thing
but they all did the same thing every
night they run the same stories at the
same time on all three networks and they
still do as a matter of fact and the
only difference is that the ads today
about halfway through begin to be the
medical ads for people my age and then
they get into the feature stories about
how our bodies are breaking down and all
that and I know they get furious with me
here this kind of thing but it's true
and you all you have to do is watch it
but I remember I was just I just said
you know I had a civics class that
lingerie Jefferson High School and this
didn't seem to be the way it should work
and often only one side would be
reported on a story and all that stuff
so I just without money without any
pedigree without anything started asking
people in the cable industry can we do
something
like this can we expand the kind of
public affairs programming I've always
thought that hearings would be the most
important thing and I got about a
hundred nose because no one could see
how this could work and in 1974 the
satellite one up and I kept asking the
question when I was writing for
cablevision magazine a bit of a conflict
I must say and one day I was invited and
I was only a camera member elde it was
probably bout 33 or 34 to a meeting of
40 cable operators at the Mayflower
Hotel where they were inviting people in
and at and asking them to present ideas
at that time in the game there were only
about three channels up on the satellite
there now 500 but at that time there
were only about three channels up there
and so they asked me if I'd like to make
my pitch they'd all heard it they
probably got tired of me coming in and
tired of me saying no to me but they
said come in and make your pitch and see
what happens so I went in on a Saturday
stood up in the room scared to death
nervous as I could be made my pitch
thinking that this is going to be
another you know fruitless opportunity
to talk and no one's going to listen and
this is what happened afterwards
everybody afterwards milling around two
men came up to me and I've always loved
this story because one man is bald and
Jewish and liberal the other man is tall
full head of hair and a Presbyterian and
a former John birchard they were in the
same company together they were very
much attracted to one another one lived
in Texas one lived in Connecticut and
these two guys said to me simultaneously
we liked your idea I think we can help
you and that began the process of
eventually leading to them giving me
$25,000 and saying take our name and our
money and go see if anybody else will
pay any attention and that's exactly
what I did it was kind of a Ponzi scheme
I went from one person to the other and
the biggies in the business looking for
new programming saw this as a way to do
new programming and they saw it also as
a way to do new program
that wasn't expensive relatively
speaking because at that point it was
home box office and Showtime and they
were been in big money for movies and
all that stuff and without going into
any more detail on it which would bore
you that's how it started I went to 22
different people they all chipped in
something and that was the little pot of
about four hundred and eighty thousand
dollars that got us started and it was
for a lot of different reasons the first
reason was we think we like your idea
the last reason was because the last guy
said yes I'll say yes and that's the
whole story of what I've always said was
like the Constitutional Convention you
know there were 55 delegates only 39
signed it three were against it and a
bunch of never showed up and it was
Rhode Island where Ken Masucci started
our Tocqueville to her that was the last
one to approve the Constitution so it's
you they're not all they're not all
going to do exactly what everybody else
is going to do but it's one of those
wonderful stories where private business
people decided to do a public service
and that's how it started is that
something gentlemen over here comment in
a question yeah joe ryan is my name
that's not common you talked about
people little people rising two levels
of power in this town which and then
mostly the little people who raise those
levels and and you mentioned arrogance
and and just the comment i would like to
make particularly because there are so
many young people here is just remember
that your behavior is rewarded by who
returns your phone calls after your out
of office the other question the
question i have that you asked of the
folks but what's your take on snowden
i'm going to not answer that
I've tried very hard in my time and
she's been not to get in the middle of
these controversies because my opinion
isn't any better than anybody else's and
it's I will just say this much I don't
really know what I think right now I
find this to be very very confusing and
it's not just that it's everything
that's going on in town I did think this
president was going to be transparent he
he's told an awful lot of people when he
ran that all the healthcare negotiations
were going to be on c-span I thought it
was always very interesting because he
never asked if they could be gone c-span
and we are private we do not march to
the government's tune we don't march
away from it either but we don't march
to their tune and when in time came
there were no negotiations televised by
us there was one that didn't matter in
the white house at one point which was a
show there was one that happened in the
Blair House which we televise but I will
say this about the other part of your
comment I can remember you know I'm no
longer the chief executive officer a lot
of people thought I had power when I was
chief executive officer they didn't
understand that I didn't and I wouldn't
I didn't make decisions on programming
and I kept telling them that but they
kept calling my desk and I made a lot of
people mad because I wouldn't take their
calls but I will remember one very
well-known television correspondent who
had been retired from his network you
notice how I said that he had been
retired from his network and he called
me one day and said he's actually was
from my state of Indiana and he said and
I had no relationship with him
whatsoever he was on the other end of
the phone he was very chummy this is
about ten years ago and he said you know
I I just love to get together with you
and had lunch well I knew there was no
way that he wanted to Chum with me at
lunch it just wasn't and I said by the
way so and so I just want you to know in
case you were thinking about this that
we we don't have any jobs
were people that were in network news I
mean we tried very hard not to have a
pedigree at all but I said we just don't
have any i mean we don't pay that kind
of money and where and i said but i'd
like to have lunch with you anyway and
he said well I tell you what I think
I'll pass on that so I've had enough of
that happen in this town that you know
I'm ready for it I expected I have no
expectations anymore on almost anything
but I'm sorry to dodge the Snowden thing
it's fascinating and that actually love
to know what some of these folks think
because it's going to be your world that
this kind of stuff happens more more yes
sir in the back my name is Maureen UN's
I'm not one of the students but i have
taught here in Washington you look like
the last 20 years that's good to hear
it's I'm in my 60s actually Wow but my
question is this if i recall correctly
the headline for today's event was
political power in the media and the
message and i'm getting from your
presentation here today which is also
very entertaining a course but the
message I'm getting is is that political
power is primarily about the money have
I misunderstood you yes and no
understanding what happens you must
think about where the money comes from
and and I've learned that just by living
it all the time and we have a very good
funding base and has been that way but I
have to tell you we're totally dependent
for our future on the cable television
executives totally and that's one of the
reasons that we've kept the price of
this service down way way down I think
though that political power today is no
longer in the hands of the few
organizations that was in when I first
got here and I think that's very healthy
I am one of those it listens to talk
radio night and day believe me night and
day I am one of those it loves every
newspaper I can find on the streets I
was disappointed that the exam
went out of business because I love
print I'm old-fashioned asst I'll get
out I think that today anybody that
wants to get their message out has a
place to do it one of the quietly hugely
successful things that's happened in my
lifetime is the Drudge Report which by
the way drives people in the the
old-timers in my business nuts they
can't believe and for all the reasons
you would expect and I don't want to be
critical of them so much is it just
drives them crazy that he's been as
successful as he's been I think
political power today has been dispersed
there are still pockets that have a
tremendous amount of power but the best
thing that we have going for us as a
country in my opinion is the checks and
balances or are the checks and balances
I mean if we didn't have the checks and
balances we would be toast because the
more power people get the more they want
and the more they get the more often
restrictive they are the more they want
to do things that they never would do if
they were out of power I always love it
when I meet somebody who has been a
united states senator or a cabinet
officer or at the White House who begins
to bad-mouth the system after they've
gotten out and it always amazes me as I
want to say to them why didn't you do
something when you were there well it
was too much fun when I was there so the
money thing to me is the first place i
go on almost everything where does the
money come from then you can better
understand i don't care whether it's
Hillsdale c-span or the Washington Post
you can understand why they do what they
do we have time for one more question oh
let's just take two very quickly because
there were two hands up yeah why do you
suppose that the media hasn't done
anything like the holding to hold up
people's feet to the fire about
responding to situations in Benghazi
various issues got handles I like they
do would have 30 or 40 years ago I would
think you would not I don't believe it
would have been let off the hook so
quickly I don't know that I know that
we've gotten a lot on Benghazi and I
would just say this to you and I don't
want to go any farther than this you've
got a far more on Benghazi because of
the media structure now then you would
have when I first came to town that
would have been an easy one just to move
aside if the mainstream didn't want to
talk about it it was over and and so
this goes for both sides I'm someone who
watches Rachel Maddow at night and watch
his bill o'reilly and i watch what's
going on with both sides and i really
like the fact that both of them are
there yes sir you had a question yes mr.
lamb my name is Bill Janice and I saw
your interview with the Patrick Gavin of
Politico and the thought just occurred
to me do you believe that technology is
helping to disperse political power
because I watched you guys for I mean
good 45 minutes and he provided numerous
examples of things of which I hadn't
been aware and technology just just
mushrooming in terms of getting out an
individual's political message
absolutely technology is everything and
you go back to the reason why we exist
it's because of the satellite in the
cable industry and as soon as there was
a low-cost delivery system which was the
satellite we were able to get into
business the best way to describe that
is if I had wanted to help start c-span
before the satellite it would have
probably cost me 15 million dollars to
get to all these communities because I'd
have to go to AT&T I had one source that
was at period and when i started with
c-span it costs us one hundred dollars
an hour think about that because of the
satellite it was impossible to dream
about doing things that were unique to a
small audience youtube today is amazing
what the power of YouTube the fact that
I stand here after
our archive and have 200,000 hours of
history that it's available free of
charge is mind-boggling and frankly we
did it because of a very smart guy named
Robert Browning is a professor at purdue
he's the one that built it it belongs to
C span but it doesn't cost us that much
to maintain and it's an amazing thing so
it's all about technology because the
American people are incredibly creative
people around the world are creative now
that we have these different places to
go you see the kind of stuff that we saw
on that program in furness to Pat
Patrick Gavin of political was a great
guest those are decisions to put those
videos on there and have him explain how
they fit into the system but want to do
some more of that because there is so
much going on that we don't know about
that it's worth doing one more quickly I
know you're in hurry this gentleman had
his hand up go ahead and write their the
blue shirt and I'll shut her down I just
wondered you we've heard a lot with all
the NSA stuff and some of the other
stories about ranking this president he
came in saying to be the most
transparent in history and now people
want to talk about going the other way
you'll have some kind of extreme Colin
so you've been here since before Nixon
how when you're looking at him against
his own promises and against the track
record of its predecessors without of
you what do you think of how he's done
on that front they've all done the same
thing I I stood around lyndon johnson 42
years as enabling the most magnificent
experience you could ever imagine I mean
you talk about and then having the
ability years later to start putting on
the telephone conversations in the Oval
Office on a c-span radio station which
we've done for years was just
unbelievable because I can I would be
standing next to him the same day that
some of these recordings were being made
in the Oval Office and have no idea but
all presidents promise things they don't
deliver on a lot of them don't promise
things they do deliver on and it's all a
matter where your emotions are
I would you say to anybody any issue
that comes up approach it on a
zero-based analysis ask yourself if
george w bush was president would you
like what the NSA is doing and if you
conclude yes then you better to rethink
it because in a and if you say that
you're nervous as heck because obama is
now getting to do that I mean the fact
is one person doesn't make that big a
difference in that system those federal
employees are out there all the time
they aren't going anywhere and they can
you know they can look in on this stuff
at all times I'm a privacy person that's
why I don't tweet that's why I don't
facebook that's well I don't send many
emails that's why I don't instant
message or text I don't really want to
be followed I'm not paranoid it's just
sooo not people not know what I'm doing
it not doing anything wrong ever since I
got married eight years ago I've been
behaving very very well thank you all
very much